thank you
uh
thank you i'm flattered to have been
selected for the the talk i feel very
lucky
sorry
come here
okay
so um
i thought they were what i would do is
instead of going through the slides
again
uh well we could have watched the
clustering movie for 20 minutes
but uh instead i will just do a a an
overview of what i said yesterday and 20
minutes is not long so
i'll just mention the results so the
it's on the stochastic block model
and i'll mention the results
for both the to symmetric
case
and the the recent result about the
general case
and then
i will expand a bit on the coding and
clustering connection
i got a few questions
about this yesterday so i thought it
would be good to expand
i'll discuss how we get to that
ch divergence
as a fundamental limit
i went quick through the proof and um
an open problem so
this will be quick and this should be
only this this one might take a few
minutes
so the model in the symmetric case
that's the one that has been mainly
studied up to now
at least for a fundamental analysis
not for implementations or the thing
is like this you have two
two groups of n over two nodes
so i'm telling you how you generate a
random graph under the stochastic block
model distribution
and then over two nodes you connect each
pair independently with probability p
inside the clusters
and independently with probability q
across the cluster
so p is equal to q is an earlier
training model
and
there's multiple uh is this a whiteboard
as well or
there's multiple uh
white
these things always happen where you end
up writing on the wall so
there's a recovery
and detection i'll just mention the
recovery now
is the property where you want to know
if there exists an algorithm
and by algorithm i'm going to call this
x and at because it's a reconstruction
of the n nodes you can think of each of
these nodes as a label zero or one this
is a group of zeros this is a group of
ones
so you want to reconstruct these
variables at the nodes
given the graph so this is a map that
takes the graph
such that
if the graph is drawn under this
sbm
which is the sim
symmetric case
that i just described
then the probability
that your reconstruction
is not the original one
tends to zero when n tends to infinity
that's the question for what and the
question is for what's
e and q
and n can you solve this
so
notice here that it doesn't matter who
you call zero and one equal to one so
well if you
when you say that this is different than
that you have to take both possible
labeling for example if you're
completely wrong you're still correct
okay it's just
all right so the theorem
is as follows if p
is l again by n
and q
is bill again by n i'll comment in a
second about why we
set the variables in that regime
then recovery is solvable
if and only if you have this equation
so this is for er
yes model
it's the stochastic block model so it's
a patching of two
so
that's the equation if you have this
nice phase transition with this closed
form expression
then uh you can recover the clusters
now if the okay why do we care about
this regime it could be that your for
example you work with a p which is a by
square root of n and q which is
uh a
times n log n that's uh let's say that's
b
that's what you care about well then you
just rewrite this thing
in that form so
if you force a log n here
you can see that this is this divided by
n times log n and then
this becomes your new a which is blowing
up this becomes your b which is maybe
shrinking so this inequality becomes the
although always true all the way or
wrong it becomes extremal so that's the
bottleneck regime that's where the
transition happens the only case that
this does not cover is that if p and q
are of the same order and then you have
to look at the second order term then
again you can have a transition
happening but as long as they have
different order this is uh telling you
what's happening in all the regimes
this is assuming a and b
to interpret this you will assume that a
and b are changing with n
yeah exactly
but he requires all sorts of
connectivity don't you
no uh there's no connectivity this is
more than connectivity connectivity
would be just this
connectivity would be that this is more
than one so if you write this like that
this is the condition for connectivity
so you need the graph to be connected in
order to recover the nodes if there's an
isolated nodes you know what to do with
it but you need more you need that extra
sampling
oh yeah that's the that's for
connectivity but what i'm saying is that
once you know you need login for
connectivity this would be the condition
for the connectivity but now you need
more
all right
so
now the general results so the general
model
you have key groups
of arbitrary sizes p1 p2
p3 b4
so you have the this vector p which is a
probability vector
k is the number of groups
number of clusters
p is the relative size of each community
and then you have that matrix q
where the q i j entry it's a symmetric
matrix tells you how a group in
community i and j connect so this is q
one two how
group here and here connect this would
be here you have a q q44 that tells you
how knows within community for connect
and once you specify that symmetric
matrix with entries in zero one you know
how the connectivity pattern is
so the as general sbm depends on this
model on this parameter
and the number of nodes p that
probability vector for the relative size
of the communities and q that symmetric
matrix
which has positive entries in 0 1.
so the theorem here is as follows for
recovery i'll tell you maybe briefly but
i i don't think there will be time what
happens for detection and partial
recovery but for recovery it's like this
recovery in the sbm
and
p
and then
again we're going to look at the regime
where we have a fixed matrix q and we
scale it by log n by n
okay so now p this is a fixed matrix
doesn't have to be in zero one it's just
a bunch of positive numbers and this is
the same scaling as before
that means i multiply each element by
log n by n
it's all but in in this model if and
only if
you have that
the minimum over all i and j that are
different that's the communities so the
ing is in k
of this
divergence measure the plus
of the column
of pq
i
and
pqg
is more than one
and d plus
is this
when you look at two major we measure mu
and u these are just a positive measure
on a finite set
this would be the maximum over all t and
0 1
of
the summation over all components
let's say i is equal to 1 to k
of the arithmetic mixture of
of new mu and u minus the geometric
mixture
so some notion of distance between these
two measures and that you apply this
what is pq remember p was the diagonal
matrix which is p1 p2
dk
q is your matrix of connectivity so this
is just multiplying each row by the pi's
elements and then
the column of pq
if you look at the eighth column
this is telling you what's the
neighborhood if you look at one node if
you look at its neighborhood what it
feels like
each element of this column is how many
how many neighbors in community k e c's
in committee j that's exactly the column
of pq
in expectation
so
information technically you can think of
the following this is kind of your
channel pq
and if two columns are the same here
if two columns are the same then it
means that the node in this community
you see i and i prime
have the same exact they see exactly the
same neighborhoods so there's no way you
can distinguish those two nodes in the
graph so two columns being the same is
like a fully noisy two fully noisy
symbols like in the channel when you
have two inputs that have the same
output distribution
two output symbols have the same
distribution then you cannot distinguish
them so
so do input that have the same
distribution you cannot distinguish them
you can just merge them here the same
happens you would merge those community
they are just the same community but now
the question is how can
you would like to know what measure of
discrepancy tells you if those
communities
sees different uh neighborhoods you
would like to understand when how much
different and in which we use which
mathematical metric should you measure
difference and that's the the answer
this is the right metric
so it's not a matrix that is convenient
it's not like it really is the one that
you need to
to
to use to get recovery
that's one
and uh this it relates as i mentioned
you said in the talk this object here is
an f divergence
so so d plus is a maxima of an f
divergence
which is related to the ellinger
distance so if you want to recover this
result here
well let's
let's do it maybe
in case
so it took already 15 minutes or 10
minutes i guess
first motion yeah
so if you want to recover a symmetric
case the matrix q in the symmetric case
is like this you can actually spread
with dp inside communities and little q
across communities
and the vector p uh
okay that is a bit of a redundancy in
the notation but p1 is equal to p2 is
equal to half for the size of the
communities
so if you apply this
so p is a log n so
q is
a a b b
times log n by n
so you apply this it turns out that the
maximizer in this case is a t is equal
to half because you have symmetric
columns
and because it's t is equal to half then
it's exactly the arithmetic mean minus
the geometric mean
and this is nothing but this
so that's how you recover that threshold
in general maximizer is not at half and
this is what you have to take for the
threshold
okay
can i ask a question
yes so yeah this is for exact
identification of all classes yeah what
if i just want to have conditions
to identify one of them okay good let's
do that so let's see
five minutes or seven
there's the coding clustering thing um i
think the algorithm will have to drop
because it's too long to explain
but maybe i can then i can answer your
question uh and then say a little bit
about the open problems
so in fact this is a pretty strong
requirement to recover all the
communities let's say that you would
like to know given a block model with
some partners which community you could
recover or say you want just one so here
is the problem
so you are you have this let's say that
pq is given to you for now we can
discuss universal model at the end for
open problems but it's a qr given
do the following uh i call this a ch
embedding because it's uh it's just uh
using that matrix for the embedding you
represent each point in so this is our k
now here
r plus key
and i'm going to draw points here and
each of these points is just a column
peq i so this is pq1
this is pq2
these are the column of this matrix that
i have there the local neighborhood
and i would like to know which one i
could recover because i may not be able
to recover the remote so what you do is
you have to solve a packing problem
you have to group these guys in rk
in the largest number of groups such
that you can ensure
that any
if you look at the distance with this d
plus matrix
between any two nodes that are in
different groups it's always more than
one
if you ensure that property then you can
that you can come up with an algorithm
that tells you not in which community
this guy is uh a node is but in which
list of communities it is it gives you a
list so if now you want to know can i
extract one specific community you have
to ensure that that specific guy you're
interested in that specific community
these are not the nodes in the graph
these are these abstract points that
represent communities that this node is
a distance one from everybody else with
that distance and then you can recover
that community
so coding clustering quick
okay can you say one word about
efficiency of recovery
so
here you can do it uh
efficiently down the threshold and we
had an sdp algorithm that was n to the
five
point time and then we have another
algorithm that is a bit that is
achieving the threshold and uh we didn't
compute exactly the complexity but now
what we have in the new paper so by the
way i should mention the authors so this
theorem is with uh is with myself
bandera
alonso
uh who's interviewing all over the place
if you haven't interviewed yet he's
still time
and then there's all georgina and this
one here is a
with another student colleen sendan
also at princeton the old princeton
and myself
and
now in this new paper we have an
algorithm that achieves a threshold in a
general case with a quasi-linear
complexity
so it's that's that's thanks to the
amazing work of choline
uh not only uh it's it's it's general
but it's uh improving the complexity of
the two case okay and so quesadilla
means n to the one plus epsilon for an
epsilon positive
okay so the coding clustering is like
this
let's take the symmetric case that's
what we can do really in just in a few
minutes so you have x1 x2
xn
which are your information bits this is
which community
person one is in zero one
committee for the person too
okay
so this is this is three or zero okay
so now what you do is uh the graph is
for each pair of nodes you're going to
look
are these guys in the same community or
not
so in fact mathematically what you're
looking at is the xor right if you take
two bits you can sort them it's zero
they're in the same community one there
are different committees so it's a
linear code
but it's a strange code that you'll
never see in a communication theory
because you you take any pair of node
any and you sort them
so how many uh
the number of transmitted bits is n
information bit is n the number of
transmitted bit is n choose 2 because
you look at each pair
so the rate of the code is roughly 2 by
n the ratio
so now
each time you look at two guys
this tells you if they're in the same
group or not and then you connect them
with this channel
same group is zero the sorry zero and
you put an edge which is the output is
being one for an edge which is probably
p and you put no address property one
minus p
but if they are in different group if
the store is one you put an entries
property q and no edges with the one
minus q
so the variables you get at the output
of this channel here
which is y one two for example for this
edge is the edge variable that's what
the output of the channel is
and then here you will have y n minus 1
n
this is the last edge variable and these
variables are the graph the stochastic
block model
and the problem of decoding those
information bits from this output
variable of this channel
is the problem of exact recovery of
reconstructing the groups from the graph
so
this is really a memoryless channel it's
a dmc
we will take it so that the bias is
depending on n so it's a regime that we
may not look at in traditional
information theory the code is
definitely not a traditional code
actually there's there's one person that
has studied this kind of code that might
be in the room
i don't know uh
wherever you can with himself mike ruby
with the
with the kind of uh um
lte codes and these kind of things they
kind of take not two bits but julie k
beats they saw them and they sent them
through so that's the closest thing we
have seen in information theory
and uh but in that specific framework
then the the capacitor uh what rate you
can support on this channel and whether
you are below or above this is exactly
the problem of real life of recovering
the clusters
so from the converse perspective you
have a sort of phano type any quality
yeah so you can you can probably use
final and a student is trying to do that
so right now we need another approach
but it's probably equivalent to these
kind of things but there are okay
there's a few things to do but final is
probably one way to do
so
yes yeah
if you have such a direct connection why
is the decoding algorithm far more
complex
in the community detection case than
simply decoding this code over at the
dmc well you can decode that code using
whatever
coding algorithm you know but how do you
know it's easy
it's still a combinatorial problem
decoding an arbitrary code is np hard
now this is not an arbitrary code but
you still have to show there's some good
properties that you can decode it
so i think i have only 30 seconds for
open problem i just say one thing very
quick is that if you take the cover and
thomas
your favorite book of information theory
you can really redo it for this actual
setup because it's really a
communication problem in a specific
regime for specific codes you can look
at error exponents you can use that here
you don't have the luxury of designing
the best code no so you don't have
coding theory but you have information
theory you can look at for example if
you have multiple networks that you try
to aggregate that's like a broadcast you
have all these things that come into the
picture so i mean i can make these
things more precise if you want but uh
you can really take a lot of the
chapters and covering thomas and think
about what the version would be here and
it usually makes sense
so uh suppose that you have
these communities
you have a graph due to facebook and
then you have also a graph tool to
twitter and then you have another graph
to
gmail okay
so then you should be able to get more
efficient algorithms exactly so why
would this be
very little but just information
directly this will be a cmo channel or a
miso multiple input single outputs right
you have each time instead of having
this guy and this output you have
another set
you have sorry you have the same so it's
a
it's a cmo yeah and then you go to
another set of outputs
and now you can see what is actually the
how much can i recover from this single
input by these multiple outputs
i don't think that i've read results yet
on that
i mean these results are this is last
year and this is this year and detection
also the results are last year this year
so in essence what you have here are
graphs that are colored against uh i
mean you have multi colors in your graph
right yes so then
yeah you can maybe it should not be too
difficult it would be like a vector case
exactly it would be like a label the
edges are labeled yep
i think i'm really over time now
thanks
you might have time for one more
question
so another question let's say you don't
want to recover all the labels but yeah
just to
answer simple queries of the form is uh
you know x i and xj in the same
community oh i think could you do this
like in some linear times that hoped for
actually
yeah i didn't think about this question
uh basically you you're asking for less
than the clustering but just some
function of the clustering yeah
i think you should
be able to
yeah i i haven't thought about this
question but maybe we can
i would say yes i don't see why it
should be harder but uh
it depends on what sorry you have to
know
yeah so here i presented everything uh
where you suppose you know in reality
you don't need to know
you need to know an upper bound a number
of communities
and you need to know a lower bound on
the size of the smallest community and
then you can learn those parameters you
expect the results to be clear when a is
greater than
b yeah that's another thing if k grows
uh
i think it's are you asking whether k
can depend on the parameters yeah so i
think k can grow slowly with n like log
but otherwise it becomes i don't know if
that's a question but k can grow but not
too fast
given that your two nodes have locally
see the same distribution
yeah
because
locally distressed this distribution
that looks same so unless you grow your
neighborhood enough
i don't know how you would do that you
would not detect them
no
no
so that's why if you have two columns
that are the same there's it's hopeless
too
oh this this question sir
if you want two specific notes or just
to complete it okay maybe we should yeah
okay thank you emmanuel
um our first unlucky